we had the return of Madison Victoria f4
functional it has been the biggest
learning experience for me I am so
grateful for our relationship this is
your bachelor season 24 episode 10 the
women Zelo recap grab your glasses it's
time for roses that rose say hi
everybody it's me Lauren Zima and I'm
wearing my hair up because the higher
the hair the closer to God great episode
this was everybody what did you think of
the rose ceremony footage that we got of
the women tell all let me know in the
comments below I truly enjoyed myself
you know let's get to it so this is the
women tell all special where the women
return but remember we still don't know
where one woman was at the end of last
episode Madison had gone out into the
night last we saw she was walking out
into the outback did she run up with the
Kangaroos
is she cuddling a koala did she return
to that weird house where she and Hanna
and and Tori have talked about who had
sex with Peter kind of we'll find out
but first we have to see the other two
today is the rose ceremony so the women
are getting ready for the rose ceremony
and Hannah Anne is putting on copious
amounts of lip gloss for a reason
she's like has anything you've been
going on was any product leaving the
gloss on her lips
I couldn't tell but she's beautiful you
look like a man has the weight of the
world on his shoulders so Chris Harrison
must come speak to him and counsel him
and why is that happening amongst these
trees I don't know it was very Lord of
the Rings to me but you know they are on
a quest fresh
Harry Potter Star Wars and Lord of the
Rings how could Chris Harrison resist so
they're talking but I don't how much
good it did because two minutes in once
again we get up don't drink every time
we see Sam Peter this episode
now Peter says he's in three
relationships and that this is so hard
for him I'm in three different
relationships and this is so freakin
hard for me right now let me know in the
comments below do you guys believe him i
straight-up asked Peter at the women
tell all
taping were you really in love with
three women shameless flood and he says
he was no I do wonder if Peter truly
understands what an adult level of love
is but again let me know in the comments
below
okay her frustration in her anger in her
pain I mean then he's in tears and he
says something so important he tells
Chris Harrison that maybe he didn't
handle this well maybe like I think
about this week the right way out
there's many saying maybe he wishes he
had slept with Hannah and I'm Victoria
Lima know in the comments below I'm
talking out of the side of my mouth cuz
everything's gotten real riled up about
this Madison ultimatum sex in the
fantasy suites thing it's a reality show
guys we're all gonna be okay as long as
you have wine what did they drink in the
Shire probably like I need like a mold
is that right a mold meet a melon
[Music]
oh my god Chris and Peter are Sam and
Frodo no Frodo is so troubled in st.
Chris Harrison is Sam Sam the wise I
know what were made for Halloween so we
are in the Shire and Hannah Anna and
Victoria are waiting and they look so
cold so it will pop up anywhere at any
time
he's like a hobbit you never know where
he might be hiding until he's there with
the ring Oh an engagement ring oh but
we're all waiting and the wind is
blowing someone give Hannah and Victoria
as sweaters at the show
is late but she arrives in a cute red
dress though honestly I was just
thinking you're gonna be cold out here
no one told these women how to dress
appropriately you know they don't have
cell phones they can't open up the
weather app they're on the outback and
see what's the windchill today you know
what's the windshear today should I wear
something sheer producers can you get me
a little info can I get on the Google
for a weather report the Accuweather
Forecast
what is the Accuweather Forecast so yeah
Matty's here without much explanation
you know she's like mommy got him sooo
sorry my horse got lost on the way to
Rivendell and I took like three left
turns or an egg and all he said he you
shall not pass I was like I kind of have
to I know I gave Peter an ultimatum
ultimatum but like now I'm back maybe my
favorite line when Madison arrives under
her breath Victoria says to Hanna an
she's here and Hanna and says oh she
learned from Daddy Rick don't waste the
word don't even waste a word now this
was interesting Madison tells Chris
Harrison she was falling in love with
Peter I was fine I love them oh no a
fireman who correctly last episode when
they were up on that building she said
she was in love with Peter man I just
realized I'm in love with and now she's
saying that after last night she doesn't
know I know but she's here where'd you
guys
I think that the wines went up it went
back into the glass that's amazing and
the rose ceremony is beginning and we
thought that we'd had sad Peter but we
didn't know we were gonna get something
Peeta absolutely destroy me
are there any tissues in the Shire you
all have a little piece of my heart I
mean wow wow wow you guys this season
has had a lot of first bachelor
historians help me out has a lead ever
cried at a rose ceremony before oh let
me know in the comments below
so Hannah Anne gets a rose and they have
a long hug and don't drink for every
heartbeat you hear
and oh my goodness this music it's so
intense it's so emotional is this that
full orchestra from Peru that was
underutilized is that what they been
working on this entire time the score
for the finale gives us so an Emmy and
then we don't know what the windshear
was but whatever it is it is blowing so
hard that it blows the petals right off
the rose things are literally falling
apart so Peter has one rose left and
look I think we all knew that Madison
was going to get that remaining
disintegrating rose right not prepared
Fuller was the way that Peter's voice
would crack as he said her name he's
like she's like what does that mean sang
Victoria so it's so windy here I can't
hear it did you face he already said
she's still getting out that rose it's
like falling apart you know what
actually it's the gift that keeps on
giving drink every time you were totally
unprepared for what would happen during
the next few minutes of this episode
Madison gets the Rose but kind of looks
like she wants to kill Peter and she's
all quiet like maybe she won't expect
the Rose
and Peter's literally waving it in front
of her like Hello it's right here and
she says yeah and then Peter looks like
he might cry again and he's like are you
sure okay honestly how much did you guys
love watching this this is wild it was
amazing it's the gift that keeps on
giving even if you don't want to accept
the gift even if the Rose is right there
and you're not really sure even if you
previously gave an ultimatum anyway more
heart beats don't drink luckily everyone
seems to be in good cardiovascular
health mentally and emotionally unclear
quick break from the tension to applaud
Chris Harrison and Peter Webber's suits
with no ties look I'd love that
and we're back and seriously was this
the saddest don't be is most delicious
rose ceremony of all time let me know in
the comments below use the wind shear to
blow your fingers across those feet
boards everybody and the wind is
bringing back the wine okay Victoria I'm
sorry and again drink for being
unprepared
Victoria F has been sent home and for
the first time the entire time she's
been on this show
she did not victoria freaked out
[Music]
I really couldn't believe that you guys
she's being sent home by the man that
last week she was crying over saying she
was in love with she was totally cool
calm and collected Victoria asked for
faring fairly well I mean Hanna ABS
crying more and Peter's crying more and
we do get an explanation from him he
tells Victoria F that his heart was
simply further along with the other
women and again I wonder Peter said he
was in love with all three I am in love
with three woman right now
so is he saying that there are different
levels of love
comments below okay Victoria F says that
she thinks the convo with Madison and
her giving Peter the ultimatum swayed
Peter I think the conversation
eatos be I will say I disagree and even
if it did Victoria baby you don't want
to be with a guy who's gonna get swayed
in his love for you by one conversation
with another woman okay so baby more on
her later so we're down to our final two
and Peter tells Hannah Anna and Madison
that his family is already here at
Middle earth damage to us back to
America
I need Barbie here okay Wow Madison last
week she said actions speak louder than
words like actions speak louder than
words and this week Madison serving us
some good television again she said
cheers to seeing if love can conquer all
seniors love can conquer
honestly guys at the end of the day
Madison and Hannah and have both been
women who overall the season have not
caused trouble with other women in the
house Peter seems very invested in both
of them so this is the final two that we
have and I applaud them both and who do
you think theater will end up with in
the end if anyone let me know in the
comments below that was one of the most
emotional rose ceremonies I have ever
witnessed and we're back in the studio
and Chris Harrison says something
unforgettable and I don't know maybe
even regrettable we'll have to wait and
see he says that not a single person not
even sad Peter knows how this season
ends there is not a single person who
knows how Peters journey will end not
even Peter right well what I mean they
cut to the audience and they're like oh
I'm confused is this an ultimatum
it's really windy in here I'm me already
said you want to get a drink after this
yes okay Arroyo see the women are here
and as usual epic tells the
back row I largely don't remember this
is how it always is Chris introduces
each woman and some of them have like
change their hair or their very glammed
up and I'm like who are you
but I will say that they all looked
beautiful
thank you say that okay ladies good to
see you all again but many of you have
pointed out the two key women were
missing Natasha and our legal eagle
Kelly being honest I do not know anymore
than you on why they weren't there I
have seen the tweets that Kelly was
responding to people who were DMing her
on Instagram and saying she wasn't
invited so she wasn't there I don't know
but what I do know is that Chris
Harrison opened this dialog beautifully
by saying that he hoped everyone was
wearing the appropriate linger e like a
cute pajama linger reset because this
was gonna be often asked o everybody
after the fonescu
I hope everybody wore their most
comfortable lingering when all the women
were doing was mispronouncing common
verbiage on this show when you go on
this show you know what happens in
fantasy suites
oh goodness and then right off the bat
we're discussing ultimatums again I just
didn't think it was fair to him to give
him that ultimatum has your opinion
changed on the ultimatum let me know in
the comments below moving on now we're
watching old footage of the show and
gosh this feels like a lifetime ago
doesn't it so much has changed I kind of
forgot about this stuff like all the
Alea things but these women haven't
they've been waiting and dying to talk
about it so we're gonna get right into
it and I hmm
now I don't know what the word of the
episode was but I know what it wasn't it
wasn't resolution Sydney what was your
take on the two of them because we get
into an in Sydney is still calling a
laya scripted my honest opinion of
Belaya is that she is scripted and then
things are descending into arguing
really quickly and I honestly couldn't
understand what any of them were saying
they were just yelling and talking over
each other like this it was like this I
couldn't drink because the words were
evaporating and ascending into it
new dialogue I can't understand a single
person I didn't or somebody was trying
to say they were talking over each other
I was just like oh my gosh ladies we
cannot move forward if you cannot listen
listen to his Barbie doll comedic age
I'll tell you what we're gonna take a
quick timeout guys so press is invited
to the tell-all tapings and so I go
every year and I interview the
contestants and I'll be honest I bring
Advil
I do I pass it around everybody so
medicate safely you know what I'm saying
okay I think the most admirable thing
that a person can do at one of these
tell-all specials is to own what they've
done to apologize for it if necessary
and to move forward it's about owning
it's about atoning and it's about
growing that's my biggest regret in this
is that I didn't just shut up I word
vomit and so I'm going to cheers to
every woman who did that tonight first
stop Aleya cuz I've done it for 25 years
my mom calls it my princess voice I saw
it then she used to Kelsey like I
overreacted it's about owning it's about
atoning and it's about growing but I
already did apologize to you I work good
really fine okay oh but then we're
really in it then we're back to the Tami
and Kelsey fight and we're talking about
the drinking and the crying and the
pill-popping and then they turn into pop
pop I never called you an alcoholic and
we didn't get to any real resolution
here everybody so you know what
without our legal eagle Kelly I'm ready
to be the judge and jury and my ruling
is Timmy you shouldn't have said the
Kelsey had alcoholic tendencies that was
taking things too far you're not a
doctor you don't know her that well and
I could follow her for years to come so
be aware Kelsey you should be aware of
your emotional energy I understand that
it's good to feel and show your emotions
about your emotions to affect other
people so just be cognizant of your
energy okay we've robbed you put on a
show it was from night one now McKenna
is still getting called up for allegedly
trying to become famous from the show
all you do is just dance like a buffoon
in front of the camera Patrick I
no I'm not gonna change hi I will say
that I do wish we'd seen more
lip-licking during this tell-all special
[Music]
the company you don't know when it's
gonna happen
[Music]
I don't really own either geumja kind of
I want to put a pin in this cuz I want
to move forward just we're gonna we
could do this all night and my ruling is
you two are never going to agree but
you're both fun to watch so i order you
to both go to bachelor in paradise I'll
be honest this is the Harry Potter
wizard's robe it's a child's costume
you're a wizard Harry and by the way
don't drink every time if somebody had
it
crying voice quivering home it was Eva's
Oh Madison my mom calls it my princess
voice I'm sorry and you taught me a lot
about myself
you've taught me like on how I don't
want to treat people Kelsey come join me
in the hot seat and then Kelsey's in the
hot seat and she gets a big champagne
and I thought nice I wish I would you
know would have let him love me
whether he wanted to and then Victoria s
is in the hot seat and I thought this is
captivating what did you guys think of
Victoria F in the hot seat let me know
in the comments below I have to say it
felt like a total 180 on this human
being cheers - every time Victoria F
owned it in a town it I mean she really
laughed at herself communication was
difficult I don't know I thought she
apologized to Peter and also I'm sorry I
loved seeing this growth seriously as
Chris Harrison said this is the woman
Peter fell in love with and I see it now
oh where was this woman all season of
Victoria at Fort where they'll give you
Ben did your opinion change in Victoria
have let me know in the comments below
any now now Peters here and it's
interesting because remember earlier in
the season the women were so frustrated
with Peter allegedly rewarding the drama
and you got a did and now they're all so
nice to him I'm just honestly grateful
for you they're loving him I trust that
you know what you're doing because truly
at the end of the day everybody theater
I think really is a good guy he's very
kind and gracious every time I've ever
met him I think he was as he has said
following his heart through this whole
thing it's just no it's a real quest
it's like you wish you had your eight
friends with you as you tried to not put
the ring on until you were ready and you
had to go through a lot of dangerous
areas and then Madol a lot of villains
along the way and at the end of the day
just wanted to find that perfect partner
that best friend you could live the rest
of your life with Peters Frodo
do you get what I'm saying JC you're
with me on this Chris and I went to
Australia for Christmas and on the way
back I didn't know what I wanted to
watch I couldn't sleep so I just
re-watched every Lord of the Rings movie
did you guys know that koalas were used
to make the sounds that the orcs make I
learned that recently
do you regret giving some of these other
girls that caused a lot of drama so much
opportunity it's know you and oh my
goodness cheers to Peter he is
confronted about whether he rewarded
drama and he says he's learning from it
so he's owning a tone and growing I feel
like if I can learn from that moving
forward and be a stronger man and a
better man at the end of that I'm okay
with that
Cheers and speaking of growth and I do
need to get serious a forum oh the women
tell all also included this segment
event is again a first for the franchise
Rachel Lindsay came in sat with Chris
Harrison and spoke with the ladies about
online hate about the difference between
critiquing the show giving your thoughts
and being unacceptable towards other
human beings on the Internet
I want to applaud the show for doing
this I was there in person and to
witness
Rachel reading out some of these tweets
and diems was so emotional I know that
it really affected her and you guys we
should all be adult enough to know that
there is a separation between saying
your opinion on a reality show and
messaging people horrible mean
unacceptable things
so cheers to you if you are a grown-up
who knows what's okay and what's not
this is one of the most unexpected and
complicated endings and then a CO sneak
peek we see what's to come in the finale
and it's very Australian we start with
music from a didgeridoo and then there
are kangaroos dingoes are a part of this
montage as well Peters wandering through
the wild and he's in love with everyone
is literally split between your two
women and oh my god his parents that
they seem to have concerns about women
do you see yourselves as being
completely compatible a little bit
concerned because it's importantly never
to change him and him never to change
him everything in me wants to hold back
and just tap out
I feel like I'm hanging on by three and
then Peters gonna get this crazy news
that we've been teased too all season
and he will be telling someone that he
is so very sorry we go
we're home to us the two love stories
are beta what an episode of The Bachelor
again I was at the women tell all
special I interviewed many of the
contestants and Peter himself and you
can see those gonna be real easy online
calm very importantly I asked Peter
Peter why do you not want easy but want
crazy mm-hmm
I am also available to you on the
instagrams the Twitter's and the app
cameo if you'd like a personal message
from me I cannot wait for this finale
you guys I think it's gonna be truly
unbelievable and we are gonna watch it
together thank you for being a part of
this season I love you all so so much
coming in on everybody with a blog and
some coffee to talk our new leading lady
Claire Crawley I have been up since very
early to learn who are new the
Bachelorette would be and how do I feel
so excited so Rob Mills in Chris
Harrison Rob is an executive you see had
both told me in interviews that they
didn't want to address a fan frustration
with the cast members being a little too
young as of late more importantly
perhaps a little bit too immature well
Claire is 38 years old the pendulum
really swung the other way
our oldest Bachelorette ever I think its
new and exciting Claire has in the past
served us strong woman vibes on Juan
Pablos season emotional vibes funny
vibes you know she infamously I spoke to
a raccoon on bachelor in paradise and
that creates drama I don't want
I think it's gonna be great television
and that's always what I'm looking for
the most guess there are other women who
were candidates and who are wonderful
people but this is new and exciting and
different and we were gonna get some
beautiful salt-and-pepper men on her
season and also I'm excited to see a
leading lady date maybe some younger
guys cuz again to me it's about maturity
and experience not necessarily age
forgot to talk about the spa Nath Lee so
we have a two night live finale Monday
March 9th and Tuesday March 10th and
because the show is going live we are
two roses and Rosie will be live right
here on this YouTube channel right after
the airing of the bachelor finales
Monday night and Tuesday night so 7:00
p.m. Pacific Monday and Tuesday come
here I'm gonna be live reacting to what
we just saw I'm gonna be taking your
questions and comments live here and
we're gonna be drinking wine life of
course very fun so don't miss it see you
next week bye and for those of you who
have been with us you know that our
motto for 2020 has been chic and Chris
Annan JC have taken that to heart JC in
a suit with no tie
Chris San in a high-waisted pant can
Peter make a decision I'm not sure maybe
he can't
[Music]